guys what more can you say about already
nobody what more can we say about the
International this year had it all from
incredible plays to the memorable
emotional out of game moments and if
that's what you're looking for we have
an entire video dedicated to that called
the best of the International 2018 but
honestly after such an incredible
tournament after such a tense grand
final that made us all hold our
collective breath I feel like it's time
to unwind and take a look back at some
of the fails and funny moments from tea
I feel like I just improved by about 2k
NMR but we're gonna throw back the real
professionals on the panel and
Oh inaudible
what do you think is the biggest thing
standing between you and the aegis Oh
[Music]
crying inside we got a problem with the
bassoon right we're gonna pop it open
make it ready to play for summer okay
pop it open in a play back to me I'm
gonna get a belt but I can play it right
now if you really want to so many teams
that are looking high speed it felt like
a lot of the middle-of-the-pack teams
we're just sort of falling the pattern
of okay we have a top we have a top lane
and a bottom Lane and this is not legal
legends folks this is the most complex
video game that's ever existed this
isn't a video game to the a ibrehem this
is its entire existence an endless
pointless loop of playing the same
stupid game over and
/ and wait Paul I'm sorry this is a
description of the human players the
line is triple kill triple three is and
you've killed three heroes I don't
understand just like three three kills
triple with three heroes three you've
killed more than two people in less than
four please email me at gaben at valve
software calm and let me know about your
rampage I'm not wearing underwear okay I
mean quite frankly the knowledge in his
brain is incredible
alright boys I need some more
predictions let's get some our
predictions out yeah I mean maybe it's
because he's a pro player and he just
knows he'll they think you're such a
good boy there's so much easier to talk
to than the house tiki skanking new Volk
ratar-o you're a much better kisser than
told honestly I have no idea how he does
it this is lucky
yeah she's Ricky Oh Nicky hello Lika yes
what's wrong with this cow oh my god
[Laughter]
hardly hold me never let go
[Music]
you ever caught anything that wasn't a
fish or a sea animal
what
[Laughter]
oh by the way licky was delicious what's
so good I understand that everyone tries
to be comfortable when they're playing
but this this gotta [__] stop right
now
[Music]
seriously while you're doing this
I've lost six [__] T eyes Big Bear
makes me myself at a point many of our
fans don't notice but the bill is
actually our approach Boris
Boris is good for the team
he keeps team focused and strong yes
what can you tell us about the way your
team played that last game how important
of a world did Boris play in this one he
beep you'll know the same thing as last
year huh
what was it like did you did you ruin
the game over 9000
[Applause]
[Music]
does he owe you that
yeah that's Kylie's thing wait guys and
I think there's some players so you
don't have that gross the TZ good
example he's amazing skill player but
doesn't always play the same game of Ti
I think there's other examples you can
look at where often the pressure will
get the Canadian on the plane so whether
that's there as well it's like a great
anime battle you know like sumail and s4
they keep their hopes alive of being the
first to repeat as TI champions that's
what it works
that's the coupe's of evil geniuses you
can see the state he's not happy how did
he get behind the bar wow man
start the [__] out here this is mica I'm
sorry this interviews look this isn't
great it's what it's great it's what
it's great Thank You puppy there you
have it folks
puppy rating this interview a ten out of
ten I've enjoyed it once again yeah you
did it's fantastic
no no stop please just stop thank you
stop I mean it we just calm down chill
please oh I got one I am gonna kill you
what the hell man red eye I'll be honest
I thought it was you
it was now why why would I do that
because you're British we're also in
British Columbia first [__] class you
still haven't explained this to me you
just put up on silently and didn't
explain what's happening behind do this
again sometime
on a level playing field in real magic
giving us the notes out there as well
okay I wonder if anyone
excuse me ma'am would you mind getting
rid of this for me thank you very much
[Music]
yeah what a lovely lady and I think that
wraps it up for us you said you would
sing with me you're gonna be ready and
dance okay
[Music]
that was way better than I thought it
was gonna be shaggy
keep up the good work and keep funding
fun people we're getting soon well
[Music]
oh yes and now I talk and I talk like
you
[Applause]
[Music]
my golly I've been looking for you my
whole life
oh hello crystal Maiden right yes that's
right I gotta say you fill it out a lot
better than Isaac
oh you're looking amazing right here
well done you're definitely not creepy
at all
this is wonderful you nailed it so now
what's your motivation Oh money money
money money there you go Oh
what are you gonna do it at Target I'll
take the machine come here with the
Canucks Jersey Vette I got like more of
an upper bracket team down on the floor
to you know bring Johnny T back sorry
guys players practice all year round
40i4 that one shot at glory that one
shot at holding the aegis of champions
but even the most veteran of dota
players can crack under the pressure of
the grandest stage of them all look guys
dota 2 is a really hard game pretty low
[Music]
on top of it it actually looked like
miscommunication because the tornado was
already flying out and septa saw this
amazing of the charities one of those
moments both of the players see this
great play at the same time but the
spells don't synergize very well yeah
and so I thought Thompson threw out the
tornado too late but as a matter of fact
they kind of just use them at the same
time it's just it's unfortunate it's one
of those things that can happen and once
that does that fight was just a clean
sweep for LGD all right how can I
predict if you are the wrong heroes what
are you doing your dilly-dallying around
what the no no this is wrong this is
wrong why is not a clear what is going
on here what's going on
support Phoenix and we've seen our TZ
side Lane ta all in one day and this is
why he's won how many tears
[Laughter]
[Music]
he mostly just leaned into though so
that these jokers just free farming and
nobody toss into our the creep blocks
and however CCNC didn't have the right
angle and this allows no one to jump
down they can try and capitalize by this
Pro another double son from Roger right
place right time they have to be careful
as Morana will buy back for more detail
about the supposed CC and see a die back
it could be a leap away turn around and
get out of there he turned for the fight
into Randy's new hands Ahuh knew he had
the extra life and VP know what they
don't run a tipsy C&C they're trying to
tell CCNC
DC and see is chasing intelligently
pullin hopes the pkp cheese must be used
my I don't know who's dropped a media
with her recently I like the concept
behind it but the timing just doesn't
suit or Bottomly dude look
rule number one oh boy of dota 2
oh good trying to win TI yes the less
you care to hire your chance of winning
so you cared a lot you're caring a lot
up here a whole time and oppa didn't you
Yugi still looking good nice email on
his second life goes bowling it catches
out the Oracle as well stops and dog one
on the backside here Thompson he's just
gonna trying to TP his hero but Miss GB
he TP to the t1 what's he think he is
being painted crate gonna give him the
tip it's a G's turn to turn it around
they had to be tipping all game but
they'll tip that one that's for sure
wow that's big wow that is very big tip
tip tip tip tip tip tip just the tip
varies through sampling a process I'm
sure you're intimately familiar with
Bruno Oh No
fine I won't be sad he just found a
double damage rune an iceberg it's made
in China
yeah these dragons have a very rare
spell they use some time there's a 5%
chance that they all cast level-3 laguna
blade at the same time
Soler didn't have committee units me by
unfortunately Anna misses the stunt
completely all of fnatic is back alive
again this is starting to get really
scared of and they find the Reaper site
he had to kill how long was he dead for
3 2 1 he wants to let er rip there's
already a loser on illusion little said
level up into five words but that both
walked inside the cogs learnt on the
best position here they can now turn on
my it's worth so much no stunts no
nothing they're killed and now it's
really fortunate from og I don't think
that was intended maybe they will check
it soon on hotel oh you missed the whole
boy problematic
let's see that Merman again sir
Ramses and no one dolphin yeah it's sad
now it's just a nice movement from sites
who saw it over his coming as our that
this krandall oh yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry it's
fine RT charging for and hoping to be
able to get the frostbite the toss for
it oh duster yarn to Buster in oh no
don't just feed duster to the wolf like
that but we hop on the does manage catch
Raven
[Music]
my goodness day 2 and day 2 majorly very
important
[Music]
reveals I'm sorry if you're into the
chat wheels I apologize to make it look
good
one of those two I don't want something
in between I don't want a whole cans
Mitch for me actually I did finish my
sentence
[Music]
not just nice we got a gustas well you
see that folks we got a PM we start off
now boys does man to get a really good
over clothes for our dams coming in from
behind Raven
we wish the koto sphere
run down the mid player bet CD peso he's
got the cry dog
[Music]
like a brother is like like
oh [__] they found Pasha yeah they
didn't find [__]
[Music]
goes in with a impale finger combo -
can't even fill up like he is gonna be
kept alone for just a moment there can
be killing all the time actually
he walked into my fear no fear kill them
oh no oh it's not even our team nice
upper ones it can't be any worse than
this my god that's what happened it's
like where is huskar
[Music]
oh that's oh that's or something Oh
poopy he's gonna pay the price as well
the punches the kill
they are shook probably potent we do
also have okay he wanted to see us now
that hundred the night goes down they'll
see you but so I think
[Applause]
[Music]
and they're just they're constantly
looking to just go for these diploids
there is the blink on the shaker I mean
that's never gonna work the Fisher is
out you got a level to spin and this
should be enough damage to kill up mind
control he can take to the skies it's
universe and now the global comes after
the fact that finest stone is well onto
the bait in the woods you cannot talk
about the US when you're in Canada it's
by law is it all that conversation
Oh arrow thanks Sara
I think he has the damage banked if he's
not careful bought a kooky dorieke
teehee Olmo by stealing TVP has that why
did he turn around CCNC just don't get
hit right now that's a free kill and he
gets it he teleported like shrine or
something then came in for the chrono
something like that it was bad really
good opening
Oh will caught that one all right hold
the creek got Shack will be fine
and so alarm out neither here is going
down a persist he doesn't get anyone yep
not like this dude I saw that happen in
slow-mo I knew he was a hundred percent
dead he's gonna be able to kill duster
Rehan tp'ing anything fill on the Kronos
fear not like GQ get her over here this
is mallow fizz stalled it up enough any
now missus he's gonna be a little bit
the tower they dive in and find the kill
it's still lingers so he's already
thrown at you comple couldn't simply
just is as you'll see the first fly back
come out swamp out from xxs making sure
he stays alive big don't wanna buy back
the nectar but they may have to look you
gonna throw away his first slicing soul
c-axis immediately loses as though which
is where the support holds they could
kill it looking throughout XX has made a
lot of trouble here he's dead for 100
seconds necro even fallback aggressive
he needs to be kb TP but his TP was in
his backpack he's also been reaping he's
dead he's dead for 85 so I has a team
friend a banner on his effigy here yes
yeah there you go
I'm left hand side well you don't click
it oh yeah I don't know if that's enough
damage Wow okay there's nothing
interesting ulti usage now I have a
strategy
it doesn't work this is definitely suck
junkie my idea idea yeah please spent a
lot of time prepping for this art easy
just watching it unable to assist in
the Blitzen is this whole thing just
designed to be a living nightmare for
our TZ as valve trying to break him this
fraud sends the command and the neutral
rookie jockey mount CEO to rescue them
and there's damage oh my goodness
someone please stop he's got a thunder
to save his teammate huh nice play there
I think he's dead
look guys playing on the grandest stage
of them all is difficult setting that
stage up is apparently equally as
difficult especially for an indie
company like valve now look I'm not
saying TI 8 was a Shanghai major but it
did get off to a pretty rocky start in
terms of production and don't worry we
turn the volume down for this next
section
few hiccups here with that nothing to
worry about you see anybody worrying
about it chat you will get AB answer B
hey Vick I want to see some pogchamp TI
productions and chat right now just went
down again
[Music]
game of the second round to set it right
just want to kind of keep you guys in
the loop a little rare glimpse behind
the scenes now as you may have been
aware I over on it be said this is how
it's gonna go down and the stream
actually did go down now I've been told
why Bruno of course the tech support for
valve and the world brought this to my
attention now I don't know if you can
see this I'm sure the cameras going to
look really hard this is the source of
our woes the second the stream went live
this this little plug decided to give up
hope and life and this is why T I
started quite literally with a bang
secret need to back out no to stone hi
guys so a quick update for you elsewhere
there's a stream a on the multicast but
I want to jump up just a quick a bit
around updating you on the drafts for
the second in the series of optic gaming
versus storm as well as TNC paint
starting with oh look at that perfect
timing the game pause for me to jump in
its machine here at the multicast now of
course just to fill you guys in increase
you're probably spamming twitch channel
where over chat you're in frantically
getting upset that you can't hear the
casters don't panic no one can we're
just fixing in an audio issue but we
want to bring you all the dota camera
again Larry how are you I'm good bro
yeah you know what it wouldn't be day
one we found a couple of table
that's what's working right now but
apparently I work a small indie company
give my mic to JPL
shut up machine all right down inside
the booth way towards the draft for the
first game Peter you right slip down to
the understand this game from your
perspective a little more use to what
most would consider one of if not visto
what's your take thing having ended
their journey here at the International
not one second we'll be able to hear you
in just a second but I if you're the
timbersaw and you're the rating in this
game you're just gonna push sides out
not to worry everybody is we're gonna
give you the audio cast now it's liquid
got the roasting by the way they're
sneaking into row strategize don't worry
well guys that was truly a TI that will
live on for ages see what I did there
seriously though those were some of our
favorite moments from t I ate that made
us laugh and a few that made us throw
our headphones wait a minute
isn't the next ti in Shanghai thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]